officials now reporting more than a
hundred thousand cases a day for the
first time since back in early october
however the cdc says most of these cases
are from the delta varian not the new
omicron strain beginning today the biden
administration implementing new travel
rules to help combat the spread joe
moller joining us live over at mccarran
airport with more on these new rules joe
brian we're just a few weeks away from
christmas and now there's some travel
changes people might want to know about
now that's one of the busiest travel
times of the year starting today anybody
traveling into the united states will
have to show proof of a negative cloven
19 test before they can board a flight
now this test must be taken within a day
before departure the president has said
the goal is to add a layer of protection
as the omicron variant continues to be a
concern the stricter testing
requirements are for all inbound
travelers including u.s citizens
regardless of vaccination status now
this applies to air travel only some are
worried about the cost of the quicker
test others don't mind
i mean i was expecting it to be
tougher than it was just from the what
your friends tell you but really it was
nothing it was very easy to do
now back out here live this test doesn't
need to be done within exactly 24 hours
just one calendar day before departure
reporting live at mccarran international
airport this evening joe mohler live
local now